we not killing the kid execute her or we
going changed my perception to what AI
shows us what may or may not happen in
the future it's all packed in one movie
together and it's so well written one of
my favorite and Oscar worthy kind of
movie did you locate the weapon just a
kid John David Washington did a good job
also there's like a really cute kid with
a really cute smile how about ice cream
the languages really PE my interest
Chinese sa bahasa English Japanese as
well get into discussion with my friends
and like what do you think about this I
would highly recommend this movie It'll
be such a waste if you don't see it on a
big screen to try to process everything
that's happened in the movie it's just
mindblowing sure to catch the Creator in
cinemas on the 28th of September and of
course watch it in
IMAX the
Creator